one of my fears is that human rights
will be perceived by some critical mass
of people as a value that we can no
longer afford I do think that the values
of human rights are pretty well
entrenched today but we've also seen
that when people feel that they are
personally threatened that they're
personally in risk that there is a
tendency to dispense with those rights
particularly if you can dispense with
them against you know another targeted
group of people and you feel that
somehow by targeting those other people
you're not really jeopardizing your
rights I'm I think about this in the
context of 911 where there was a broad
feeling in the united states that you
know maybe torture was okay you know
maybe it was okay to imprison people
without trial because after all our
lives are at risk and the people that
we're targeting those are those other
people you know they're they're they're
Muslims they're there are people from
the middle east or south asia they're
young males there a discrete group of
people who you know many Americans valve
were not me and won't become me and
therefore my rights aren't at risk when
I jeopardize their rights and it's that
kind of willingness to compromise under
threat that I worry about I do think
that America has moved a long way since
then and is recognized that the initial
reaction in 911 was an overreaction much
the way see the we now look back to the
Japanese internment during World War two
as a mistake is an over reaction to the
threats of the Japanese attack
on Pearl Harbor so I hope that the
nation has gained the wisdom of a little
distance but inevitably there's going to
be another terrorist attack and
inevitably people are going to be
fearful again and so what I worry about
is the extent to which those fears will
countenance further compromises in basic
rights because if we lose the West as a
group of people who stand behind these
basic rights I think we risk setting
back the movement tremendously the human
rights movement has taken hold around
the world but we have to recognize that
that in the face of dictators and
tyrants the West is often the most
important defense and if the Western
defense waivers because it's not so sure
that these rights are of paramount
importance in light of other threats and
concerns I think the whole movement will
be very much